In this segment, we discuss the
expected value rule for
calculating the expected
value of a
function of a random variable.
It corresponds to a nice formula
that we will see
shortly, but it also involves a
much more general idea that
we will encounter many times
in this course, in somewhat
different forms.
Here's what it is all about.
We start with a certain random
variable that has a known PMF.
However, we're ultimately
interested in another random
variable Y, which is defined as
a function of the original
random variable.
We're interested in calculating
the expected value
of this new random variable,
Y. How should we do it?
We will illustrate the ideas
involved through a simple
numerical example.
In this example, we have a
random variable, X, that takes
values 2, 3, 4, or 5, according
to some given
probabilities.
We are also given a
function that maps
x-values into y-values.
And this function, g, then
defines a new random variable.
So if the outcome of the
experiment leads to an X equal
to 4, then the random variable,
Y, will also take a
value equal to 4.
How do we calculate the
expected value of Y?
The only tool that we have
available in our hands at this
point is the definition of the
expected value, which tells us
that we should run a summation
over the y-axis, consider
different values of
y one at the time.
And for each value for y,
multiply that value by its
corresponding probability.
So in this case, we start with
Y equal to 3, which needs to
be multiplied by the
probability that
Y is equal to 3.
What is that probability?
Well, Y is equal to three, if
and only if X is 2 or 3, which
happens with probability,
0.1 plus 0.2.
Then we continue with the
summation by considering the
next value of little y.
The next possible value is 4.
And this gives us a contribution
of 4, weighted by
the probability of
obtaining a 4.
The probability that Y is equal
to 4 is the probability
that X is either equal to 4 or
to 5, which happens with
probability.
0.3 plus 0.4.
So this way, we obtain an
arithmetic expression which we
can evaluate.
And it's going to give us the
expected value of Y. But
here's an alternative
way of calculating
the expected value.
And this corresponds to the
following type of thinking.
10% of the time, X is going
to be equal to 2.
And when that happens, Y
takes on a value of 3.
So this should give us a
contribution to the average
value of Y, which
is 3 times 0.1.
Then, 20% of the time, X
is 3 and Y is also 3.
So 20% of the time, we
also get 3's in Y.
Then 30% of the time, X is 4,
which results in a Y that's
equal to 4.
So we obtain a 4 30%
of the time.
And finally, 40% of the time, X
equals to [5], which results
in a Y equal to 4.
And we obtain this arithmetic
expression.
Now you can compare the two
arithmetic expressions, the
red and the blue one, and you
will notice that they're
equal, except that the terms
are arranged in a slightly
different way.
Conceptually, however, there's
a very big difference.
In the first summation, we
run over the values of
Y one at the time.
In the second summation, we run
over the different values
of X one at a time, and took
into account their individual
contributions.
This second way of calculating
the expected value of Y is
called the expected
value rule.
And it corresponds to the
following formula.
We carry out a summation
over the x-axis.
For each x-value that we
consider, we calculate what is
the corresponding y-value,
that's g of x, and also weigh
this term according to
the probability of
this particular x.
So for instance, a typical term
here would be when x is
equal to 2, g of x would
be equal to 3.
And the corresponding
probability, that's the
probability of a 2,
would be 0.1.
The advantage of using the
expected value rule instead of
the definition of the
expectation is that the
expected value rule only
involves the PMF of the
original random variable, so
we do not need to do any
additional work to
find the PMF of
the new random variable.
Now we argued in favor of the
expected value rule by
considering this numerical
example, and by checking that
it gives the right result.
But now let us verify.
Let us argue more generally that
it's going to give us the
right answer.
So what we're going to do is
to take this summation and
argue that it's equal to the
expected value of Y, which is
defined by that summation.
So let us start with this.
It's a sum over all x's.
Let us first fix a particular
value of y, and add over all
those x's that correspond
to that particular y.
So we're fixing a
particular y.
And so we're adding only over
those x's that lead to that
particular y.
And we carry out to
the summation.
So this is the part of this
sum associated with one
particular choice of y.
And it's a sum, really,
over this set of x's.
But in order to exhaust all x's,
we need to consider all
possible values of y.
And this gives rise to an
outer summation over the
different y's.
So for any fixed y, we add
over the associated x's.
But we want to consider
all the possible y's.
Now at this point, we make the
following observation.
Here, we have a summation
over y's.
And let's look at the
inner summation.
The inner summation involves
x's, all of which are
associated with a specific
value of y.
Having fixed y, all the terms
inside this sum have the
property that g of
x is equal to y.
So g of x is equal to
that particular y.
And we can make this
substitution here.
Now when we look at this
summation, we now realize that
it's a summation over x's
while y is being fixed.
And so we can take this
term of y and pull
it outside the summation.
What this leaves us with is a
sum over all y's of y, and
then a further sum over all
x's that lead to that
particular y, of the
probabilities of those x's.
Now what can we say about
this inner summation?
We have fixed a y.
For that particular y, we're
adding the probabilities of
all the x's that lead to
that particular y.
Fixing y, consider all the
x's that lead to it.
This is just the probability
of that particular y.
But what we have now is just the
definition of the expected
value of Y. And this concludes
the proof that this
expression, as given by the
expected value rule, gives us
the same answer as the original
definition of the
expected value of Y.
Now before closing, a
few observations.
The expected value rule is
really simple to use.
For example, if you want to
calculate the expected value
of the square of a random
variable, then you're dealing
with a situation where
the g function
is the square function.
And so, the expected value of
X-squared will be the sum over
x's of x squared weighted
according to the probability
of a particular x.
And finally, one important
word of caution, that in
general, the expected value
of the function--
so for example, the expected
value of X-squared.
In general, it's not going to
be the same as taking the
expected value of X
and squaring it.
So this is a word [of] caution,
that in general, you
cannot interchange the order
with which you apply a
function, and then you calculate
expectation.
There are exceptions, however,
in which we happen to have
equality here.
And this is going to
be our next topic.